the defending bridges in a round is  being knocked away by booker as brunson  was gonna go and shoot it up inside  nice play  and booker was there with the d phoenix  just such a great job of helping  i don't think they're going to give  devin booker a technical foul for tom  hooker for it's haunting  he's talking between the win in new  orleans the defending bridges in a round  being knocked away by booker as brunson  was gonna go and shoot it up inside  nice play  and booker was there with the d phoenix  just such a great job of helping  i don't think they're going to give  devin booker a technical foul for tom  booker for its haunting  williams is talking between the win in  new orleans